das ist nämlich der für digitales und
verkehr traditionell ein großer
einzelplan in der haushalts systematik
36,1 milliarden euro ausgaben sind hier
für 2022 vorgesehen und dieser
einzelplan traditionell der größte
investitionsetat für investitionen
beispielsweise in straßen schienen
wasserwegen sind 19 5 milliarden euro
vorgesehen
und ein thema wird mit sicherheit hier
eine aussprache auch sein das
angekündigte 9 euro ticket wenn man auf
die zahlen schaut das soll ja ab morgen
gelten und von schon vor dem start sind
bereits sieben millionen euro tickets
verkauft das melden heute die
nachrichtenagenturen erster redner jetzt
zum einzelplan florian oßner für die
union liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der haushalt des ministeriums für
digitales und verkehr offenbart die
ampel ist in wahrheit ein bremslicht
statt dem infrastrukturausbau in unserem
land voranzubringen werden wertvolle
steuergelder in zweifelhafte experimente
wie dem neuen euro ticket verbrannt die
ampel grenzt sich damit schon einen
ordentlichen schluck aus der
schuldenfalle leidtragender ist und
bleibt der steuerzahler wir haben ende
mit einem riesen kater aufwachen wird
und noch dafür am ende auch noch die
zeche bezahlen darf
denn von den 25 milliarden euro mehr
kosten wird kein einziges neues gleis
verlegt kein stellwerk modernisiert
keine schleuse repariert keine
umgehungsstraße gebaut und keiner
funklöcher geschlossen das ende vom lied
wird sein dass geldes verbracht das
konto weist ein dickes minus auf unter
op en v ist nach drei monaten für die
leute wieder exakt genau so unattraktiv
wie zuvor da kann man zu recht fragen
was habt ihr gemacht liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen der ampel nachhaltiges
wirtschaften sieht wahrlich anders aus
kommen wir kommen wir zu einem weiteren
sehr schönen ampel projekt die förderung
des fous verkehrs alles schön und gut
auch bei aller sympathie für das wandern
fällt es mir schwer eine zuständigkeit
des bundes zu erkennen wir brauchen hier
wahrlich mehr haushaltsdisziplin wenn
wir vernünftige haushalte haben wollen
müssen wir endlich damit aufhören die
zuständigkeiten von bund ländern und
kommunen bild miteinander zu vermischen
und sollten uns wieder auf die
kernaufgaben des bundes konzentrieren
wir als der cdu csu wollen
technologieoffenheit und einen
mobilitäts mix eben kein ausspielen von
einzelnen verkehrsträgern wir wollen
forschung und entwicklung autonomer
automatisiert zb mit automatisiert
fahren den shuttlebussen fördern hierzu
gibt es zb mein wahlkreis in kelheim mit
dem projekt keller einen interessanten
feld versucht gerade im ländlichen raum
können wir mehr derart innovativen
projekten eine viel größere wirkung
entfalten als mit kurzfristigen
rabattaktionen das wäre
zukunftsgerichtet verkehrspolitik
die die ampel betont bei jeder
gelegenheit gerne wie wichtig ihr der
ausbau der schieneninfrastruktur ist das
ist auch wichtig ein blick in den
haushalt zeigt jedoch dass dies in
wahrheit nur lippenbekenntnisse sind
sofort rot grün geht einerseits in eine
maßgabe beschluss sehr prominent im
haushaltsausschuss mehr geld in den
schienenausbau zu investieren kürzt aber
zeitgleich die
verpflichtungsermächtigungen für den
bedarfsplan schiene im haushalt das sind
krasse widersprüche und eine absolute
augenwischerei
als union haben wir deshalb einen
änderungsantrag vorgelegt und fordern
dass diese investitionen wieder das
niveau von 20 21 erreichen ich freue
mich auf ihre zustimmung auch im bereich
planungs beschleunigung ist die ampel
ambitionslos wie dringend hier
nachbesserungsbedarf besteht zeigt ein
beispiel was letzte woche in der presse
zu lesen war die länder berlin und
brandenburg
haben sich darauf verständigt die
sogenannte stammstrecke zwischen berlin
und potsdam wieder zu reaktivieren
obwohl schon viele vorarbeiten bei
diesem projekt geleistet wurde wird es
vermutlich bis sage und schreibe 20 40
dauern bis dort die ersten züge fahren
grund hierfür ist das lange
planfeststellungsverfahren am ende wird
es also geschlagene 50 jahre dauern als
ein halbes jahrhundert nach der
deutschen wiedervereinigung wo es
möglich ist diese kurze strecke zu
nutzen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
das kann und darf nicht unser anspruch
beim infrastrukturausbau sein
akzente für eine moderne mobilität
finden sich in diesem haushalt kaum ganz
im gegenteil so werden beispielsweise
mittel für das zukunftsweisende projekt
wie das deutsche zentrum für mobilität
in münchen gekürzt und
innovationschancen verspielt das wäre
eine wirkliche blaupause für moderne
vernetzung aller stakeholder im bereich
der mobilität gewesen unser unionsantrag
wo die trotz heftiger diskussion
abgelehnt ein sehr sehr großer fehler
entgegen der ankündigung der ampel in
ihrem eigenen koalitionsvertrag wird es
auch kein zusätzliches zentrales digital
budget im haushalt 2022 geben das
jetzige kompetenz wirrwarr in
zahlreichen ministerien im digitalen
bereich ist echt erschreckend wir haben
dazu einen antrag gestellt von der ampel
abgelehnt ein sehr sehr großer fehler
zusammenfassung zusammenfassend kann man
über den digital und verkehrshaushalt
der ampel sagen völlig innovation
sondern ambitionslos schlimmer noch der
von der union gestartete investitions
hochlauf kommt mit androhungen wie zum
beispiel dem straßenbau moratorium zum
erliegen wichtige verkehrsprojekte zur
entlastung von anwohnern vor ort werden
damit ausgebremst die groß angekündigte
digitalisierungs offensive beschränkt
sich lediglich auf die änderung des
ministeriums namens das reicht nicht als
fazit bleibt die sogenannte fortschritts
projektion ist als tiger gestartet und
als bettvorleger gelandet
die ampel bleibt ein bremslicht
herzliches vergelt's gott fürs zuhören
[Applaus]
florian oßner hier mit dem auftakt zum
einzelplan digitales und verkehr
als obmann im haushaltsausschuss und
als nächstes wollen wir jetzt hier für
die fdp frank schäffler
frau präsidentin meine lieben
kolleginnen und kollegen ich will direkt
auf herren osna antworten wenn man ihre
änderungsanträge im haushaltsausschuss
einmal zusammen rechnet da kommt heraus
dass die union ebenfalls oder was
ebenfalls im wesentlichen die
investitionen kürzen will also sie haben
130 millionen weniger investitionen
veranschlagt als dass die
bundesregierung und die sie tragenden
koalition hier gemacht haben also sie
machen im kern das gegenteil dessen was
sie selbst versprochen haben wir dagegen
kümmern uns um
konkrete investitionsprojekte ohne uns
wird jetzt keine vertiefung des
senats in rostock geben das haben sie
damals im haushaltsverfahren vermasselt
erst dadurch dass wir
verpflichtungsermächtigungen hier
bereitstellen führt das dazu dass dieses
wichtige projekt endlich vorankommt
aber
oppositionsarbeit reist ja nicht nur
etwas zu kritisieren
sondern vielleicht muss man sich ja auch
ein stück weit an die eigene nase fassen
und da finde ich es besonders
bemerkenswert und darauf will ich im
wesentlichen eingehen wie ihre
oppositionsarbeit im haushaltsausschuss
eigentlich aussieht sie haben ein
maßgabe beschluss vorgelegt zur
digitalisierung den möchte ich gerne
einmal zitieren der haushaltsausschuss
begrüßt dass in der letzten
legislaturperiode im bereich der
digitalisierung durch die damalige
unionsgeführte bundesregierung wichtige
weichen gestellt worden
das ist das ist die politische qualität
der haushaltspolitik der union im
haushaltsausschuss des deutschen
bundestages
und wer es nicht so traurig könnte man
eigentlich darüber lachen denn das was
sie hinterlassen haben in der digital
politik ist doch eine absolute
katastrophe
und das sagt nicht nur ich sondern da
gibt es genügend quellen und davon will
ich party tieren der international der
internationale wettbewerb index der
digitalisierung hat 2021 und damals
haben sie regiert uns auf platz 18
klassifiziert 2016 waren wir auf platz
das berliner european center for digital
kapitel
hat uns ja schwieriges wort hatte noch
hat uns in europa auf den vorletzten
platz gesetzt nur albanien ist
schlechter die g7 staaten haben uns auf
den vorletzten platz gesetzt die
g20-staaten und das war alles ihrer
regierungszeit die g-20-staaten haben
uns auf den drittletzten platz gesetz
hinter südafrika mexiko argentinien das
ist ihre bilanz in der digitalisierung
politiker netzwerk sie und ziehen nach
115 tagen vor wir hätten und nichts
erreicht ich finde dafür sollten sich
schämen vielen dank
frank schäffler war das für die
fdp-fraktion und nach wie vor sie sehen
ist der termin in brüssel immer wieder
ein stückchen nach hinten gerutscht wir
erwarten unter anderem jahr die
abschluss pressekonferenz von olaf
scholz der noch in brüssel ist und haben
ein auge darauf so lange bleiben wir
hier beim haushalt mit marcus böhme von
der afg jetzt zum einzelplan digitales
und verkehren
der grüne traum aus den neunzigern geht
in erfüllung fünf mark pro liter benzin
wird an der tankstelle so gut wie
erreicht für die pendler für die bürger
im ländlichen raum oder das
transportgewerbe ist die preisexplosion
dagegen zu einem anderen traum geworden
nämlich zu einem albtraum die hohen
spritkosten sind eine der ursachen für
die hohe inflation die den bürgern das
mühsam ersparte auffrisst ja es ist
richtig dass der krieg in der ukraine
zur weltweiten preisanstiegen führte
aber der blick zu unserem nachbarn polen
zeigt dass es nicht der ausschließliche
grund ist einen wesentlichen unterschied
zwischen polnischen und deutschen
kraftstoffpreisen stellt der hohe
deutsche steuer und abgaben anteil dar
denn es war und ist der politische wille
dieser und der vorherigen koalition
autofahren zu verteuern und eine
ideologische verkehrswende zu betreiben
sei es durch die co2 bepreisung oder
hoher energie steuern die fatalen
wirtschaftlichen folgen dieses kurses
sind inzwischen deutlich messbar
und die antwort von links gelb heißt
dann entlastungspaket was ist das ein
flickenteppich der den benzinpreis für
90 tage um 30 cent und der dieselpreis
um 14 cents hängt dieses sommer
strohfeuer soll vielleicht die bürger
etwas besänftigen eine wirkliche lösung
sieht anders aus was wir brauchen sind
langfristige lösungen wie das dauerhafte
absenken der energiesteuern das gebietet
allein die wirtschaftliche vernunft und
das zu beschließende neuen euro ticket
für 5 90 tage wird bestimmt kein
sommermärchen sohn ein support chaos
weil sie sich jetzt schon bei der bahn
andeutet in den haushaltsberatungen
haben wir viel über höhere investitionen
in die verkehrsinfrastruktur gesprochen
hoffentlich bleiben die vorhaben nicht
nur im schaufenster stehen und finden
sich nächstes jahr als ausgaben reste
wieder wie leider schon so oft
unsere infrastruktur ist stark belastet
besonders bei brückenbauwerke stehen wir
vor enormen herausforderungen in den
nächsten jahren unseren straßen wickeln
fast 80 prozent des verkehrs ab und das
muss sich auch in den investitionen und
dem erhalt im haushaltsplan
widerspiegeln wir teilen nicht die
auffassung der koalition dass die
schiene mehr mittel als die straße
erhalten soll auch diese position passt
zur politik der links gelben regierung
autofahrern immer teurer zu machen wir
können im haushalt in dieser form daher
nicht zustimmen vielen dank
nach dem spiel war das für die afg
fraktion ja die spritpreis senkung wie
energie steuern auf kraftstoffe die wird
ja für drei monate deutlich abgesenkt
auch das teil das entlastungspaket ist
das geht ab morgen doch ob das im
geldbeutel der autofahrerinnen und
autofahrern gleich sich bemerkbar macht
das ist noch fraglich
wie das technisch umgesetzt würde wie
das ganze auch an die verbraucherinnen
und verbraucher weitergegeben wird
einen sehr großen investitionshaushalt
wir bauen große bahnhöfe autobahn
neuerdings auf abwege große
wasserstraßen schleusen digitale
stellwerke und riesige bahnbrücken und
wir bauen sie nicht nur will man sich
wie angekündigt verehrte zuschauerinnen
und zuschauern gehen wir jetzt nach
brüssel und zunächst aber jetzt zur
abschluss pressekonferenz mit
eu-kommissionspräsident denn ursula von
der leyen und eu-ratspräsident janisch
hält googeln sie mal ihren wohnort und
dass wir haben 1990 und dann drücken sie
auf bilder mal gucken sie mal zu finden
und was fällt ihnen auf
tipps
so wenig autos auf der straße richtig
wenig autos auf der straße 1990 und
jetzt rechnen sie mal bis 2030 wollen
wir 65 prozent co2 emissionen im
vergleich zu 1990
im vergleich zu 1990 einsparen das
betrifft im erheblichen maße auch den
verkehr im vergleich zu 190 nicht im
vergleich zu heute also schauen sie noch
einmal auf die bilder wie wird man sagen
das sind eine menge elektroautos und
sehr viele zusätzliche bahnkunden bis
2030 wenn wir unsere klimaziele
erreichen wollen wird sich einiges in
diesem jahrzehnt wandeln müssen auch im
sektor verkehr sicherheit im wandel
bedeutet dass wir massiv in die
verkehrsinfrastruktur investieren müssen
es wäre großartig wenn der mensch vom
auto auf die bahn umsteigen es wäre
großartig wenn der güter von der straße
auf die schiene oder auf die
wasserstraße kennen und es wäre
großartig für mehr menschen das rad
benutzen würden klar ist aber auch
mobilität darf kein luxusgut werden sie
muss für alle einkommensgruppen
bezahlbar bleiben der wandel im
verkehrssektor
der wandel im verkehrssektor darf keinen
sozialen abstiegs fördern mobilität
gehört zur daseinsvorsorge
wir haben den beratungen seit der ersten
eindrücken des haushalts im märz ende
märz diesen jahres einige änderungen
vorgenommen änderungen um den wandel im
verkehrssektor schneller voranzubringen
beispielhaft seien hier genannt
zuschüsse an privatunternehmen in den
kombinierten verkehr das sind wir
unterstützen da investitionen in anlagen
die güter von der straße auf die schiene
oder aus wasser bringen radverkehr die
investieren mehr ins raten jetzt
deutschland und das sonderprogramm stadt
und land liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
in zukunft werden mehr menschen auf das
rad umsteigen weil es elektrisch
verstärkt komfortabler
weil das komfortable und weil es für
eine größere reichweiten haben dazu
braucht es auch ein richtiges
radwegenetz wasserstraßen wir haben die
mittel zur unterhaltung von
wasserstraßen erhöht für die seekanal
vertiefung rostock allein haben wir 118
millionen euro
verpflichtungsermächtigungen nächsten
jahren aus gebracht und schließlich die
wichtigste veränderung zum
regierungsentwurf für die
digitalisierung der schiene haben wir
mehr als 400 millionen euro
bereitgestellt lasse mich in diesem
zusammenhang mit dem thema
digitalisierung auf die herausforderung
der zukunft im verkehrsalltag kommen ich
sehe zwei schwerpunkte erstens
digitalisierung der schiene
zweitens erhalt der infrastruktur wir
sehen ist dieser tage immer wieder kommt
die bahn an ihre leistungsgrenze
verspätungen zugausfälle
schicht zu geringe kapazitäten auf
bestimmten strecken diese probleme
bestehen nicht nur bei der bahn
sanierungsbedürftige autobahnbrücken
wasserwege und schleusen bereiten uns
heute schon oftmals große probleme wenn
wir hier nicht schnell gegensteuern kann
das richtig richtig teuer werden wir
müssen in den kommenden jahren in den
erhalt der verkehrsinfrastruktur
investieren wir müssen in diesem bereich
unsere versäumnisse der vergangenheit
aufholen gleichzeitig müssen wir im
bereich digitalisierung der schiene noch
ehrgeiziger werden denn es schlummert
ein schatz ein riesiger schatz in
unserem trassen netz durch die digitale
vernetzung der bestehenden infrastruktur
der gleise der weichen der stellwerk mit
der signale und der fahrzeuge auf den
gleisen können die bestehenden gleise
deutlich mehr kapazität also mehr züge
deutlich zuverlässiger bewältigen dafür
müssen wir aber auch in diese
infrastruktur investieren und sie
digital ausrüsten wir wollen dass
menschen vom auto auf die bahn umsteigen
gut so dann muss die bahn aber auch
verlässlich komfortabel und preiswert
sein wir werden das nur mit massiven
investitionen in die infrastruktur
erreichen dabei sind die
digitalisierung der schiene und der
ausbau der strecken jetzt ist besonders
wichtig denn so wird das umsteigen auf
die bahn attraktiver wir haben deshalb
einen maßgabe beschlossen im
haushaltsausschuss gefasst und mit
erlaubnis der präsident möchte ich hier
dem auszug zitieren an die
bundesregierung die bundesregierung ist
aufgefordert bei der aufstellung des
haushaltsentwurfs 2023 und der
finanzplanung im einklang mit dem
koalitionsvertrag bei der anhebung und
langfristigen absicherung der
investitionen in die
verkehrsinfrastruktur
erheblich mehr in die china als in die
straße zu investieren mit den anzügen
ebenen ansetzen
mit den anzunehmen ansätzen im kapitel
bundesschienenwege sind insbesondere die
digitalisierung der schiene und die
ausweitung des streckennetzes im
bahnverkehr priorität voranzutreiben
zitat ende
damit ist dann wo alles gesagt liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der
haushaltsausschuss haben mit diesem
maßgabe schluss ein machtwort richtung
regierung gesprochen wir meinen es ernst
wir wollen die china ausbauen wir wollen
die schiene digitalisieren
wir sehen uns hier alle nach dem sommer
in der nach der sommerpause
wieder um den haushalt 20 23 zu beraten
wenn wir unsere klimaziele erreichen
wollen müssen wir massiv in die
verkehrsinfrastruktur investieren zum
abschluss noch herzlichen dank an die
kolleginnen kollegen berichterstatterin
berichterstatter herzlichen dank an die
mitarbeiterin mitarbeiter im ministerium
die referentinnen und referenten in den
arien und in den abgeordnetenbüros die
arbeit hat sich gelohnt ich freue mich
auf den haushalt 20
und auch der dankbar in der redezeit ich
nehme das als anregung für alle anderen
mit ist das so passiert und gebe jetzt
das wort im kollegen victor perli für
die fraktion geworden
[Applaus]
herzlichen dank frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren was wurde nicht alles
versprochen ein neuer aufbruch bei
digitalem und verkehr mehr güter auf die
schiene überhaupt mehr geld für die bahn
als für die straße nichts davon findet
sich in diesem haushalt die neue
regierung macht genauso weiter wie die
alte
das neun euro ticket das ist auf jeden
fall super aber es ist doch wunschdenken
wenn sie hier behaupten dass jetzt bei
bus und bahn alles besser wird nur weil
drei monate günstig fahren angesagt ist
ein euro ticket ab ich wo bleibt der bus
das doch die situation außerhalb der
großen städte deshalb muss dafür gesorgt
werden dass bus und bahn dauerhaft
günstig werden dass ländlichen raum
ausgebaut werden das ist die aufgabe
dieser zeit und das macht sie
ampelkoalition genau nicht meine damen
und herren
schauen wir auf die zahlen
die grünen auch in der opposition waren
sagte der kollege kindler ich zitiere
was jetzt im haushalt notwendig ist ist
eine klare verkehrswende mit schwerpunkt
auf der bahn dazu wollten die grünen die
mittel für den schienen neubau auf 3
milliarden euro im ersten schritt
erhöhen jetzt ist ein grüner regierung
auf neubau gibt es nicht drei milliarden
sondern 1,9 milliarden das ist genau die
summe die verkehrsminister von der csu
bereits auf eingestellt hatte keinen
einzigen cent haben sie oben drauf
gesetzt im vergleich zur großen
koalition ist es sogar so dass die ampel
die mittel für die straße deutlich
erhöht als die mittel für die schienen
beim personal dasselbe
29 neue stellen für das fernstraßen
bundesamt damit neue autobahn schneller
geplant werden aber nur neun neue
stellen beim eisenbahnbundesamt und
jetzt kürzen sie auch noch wichtiger für
die programme für die schiene zum
beispiel für den güterverkehr für die
gleisanschlüsse für den deutschlandpakt
im koalitionsvertrag versprechen sie
ganz genau das gegenteil es gibt
überhaupt nichts dabei schönzureden
damen und herren
einige denken sie jetzt vielleicht naja
das geld wird ja vielleicht gar nicht
gebraucht das behaupten die linke und
der perle hier nur aber weit gefehlt
interne dokumente aus dem ministerium
die ihm zugespielt worden sind belegen
belegen dass die beamten die für die
schiene zuständig sind bereits einnahmen
schneiden weil sogar für die wichtigsten
zukunftsprojekt zuerst geld fehlt
und von den verkehrsverbänden von den
verkehr zwei bände herrenzimmer zu
passiver kers übrigen die hoffnung auf
sie gesetzt haben jetzt sagen allianz
pro schiene allianz pro schiene sagt ich
zitiere der bundeshaushalt 22 eine herbe
enttäuschung
die ampelkoalition hat verkehrspolitisch
kein aufbruchssignal gesetzt oder sich
für ein weiter so entschieden das ist
die lage dass spd grüne und fdp hier
vorgelegt haben eine einzige
enttäuschung
zu nichts zu gebrauchen
ich danke für die aufmerksamkeit und
herren
kollege perli da ich davon ausgehe dass
sie wissen dass es im plenum untersagt
ist plakate oder transparente hoch zu
halten gehe ich davon aus dass das was
sie hoch gehalten haben ein besonders
großes aus bedruckter teil ihres
manuskripts war und gebe das wort an die
kollegin dr potter für bündnis 90 die
grünen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin die wir
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe zuhörer
sinnen das spannende ist ja dass wir
heute hier diese debatte führen wenige
stunden bevor dieses neuen euro ticket
dass er definitiv die geister spaltet an
den start geht und man kann jetzt viel
kritisieren es gibt die einen dieses
jeden tag und es gibt die anderen die
auch wirklich die vorteile betonen aber
niemand kommt in diesen tagen an diesen
neuen euro ticket vorbei weil es
realitäten schafft es sind keine
perfekten realitäten aber das ist nur
ein euro ticket auch für den begrenzten
zeitraum in dem es gilt zeigt was
möglich ist in diesem land wenn die
große gestaltungsmacht des
bundeshaushaltes der bundesgesetzgeber
die länder die verkehrsverbünde die
menschen in diesem land tatsächlich
zusammenkommen und an einem strang
ziehen
und es zeigt aber auch
der kelly da haben sie ja recht ein
halbes jahr ampel regierung macht mich
alle nachlässigkeiten und fehler der
letzten jahrzehnte verkehrspolitik
rückgängig wir müssen wir müssen jetzt
wo wir von der realität eingeholt werden
und wo wir tatsächlich ganz schnell
unabhängig werden müssen auch im
verkehrsbereich von fossilen energien
und das zum beispiel mit dem neuen euro
ticket versuchen müssen wir das schaffen
der in der situation wo wir aber
trotzdem nicht die vorarbeit vorfinden
die eigentlich hätte geleistet werden
können für eine richtig gute
verkehrswende wir schaffen realitäten
aber wir erkennen an dass sie unperfekt
sind weil die vorbereitung um perfekt
war und das ist die realität auch nach
einem halben jahr ampel regierung und
jede schlagzeile zu jedem zug der
überfüllt sein wird zu jedem bus der
überführt sein wird und zu jeder
überlasteten bahn geben die wird uns und
aber was ja noch viel wichtiger ist den
menschen im land sein dass uns das nicht
noch mal passieren darf und das haben
wir deswegen im parlamentarischen
verfahren gemacht jetzt in diesem
haushalt 22 wir uns ja nicht mehr
wahnsinnig viel zeit bleibt verwehrt
nachdem wir den beschlossen haben nur
noch ein halbes jahr zum aufgeben des
unbeschichtete geldes haben und wo wir
auf der anderen seite auf der anderen
seite aber auch sehen dass wir nicht
alles korrigieren müssen korrigieren
können was auf kabinett seite nicht
geleistet wurde deswegen haben uns
konzentriert auf die punkte und meine
kollegen hans teilweise sind wir
angesprochen die tatsächlichen diesem
jahr noch sinnvoll machbar sind und
haben aber auch geschaut und kollege von
mir meinte neulich jetzt wo wir regieren
fällt mir zum ersten auf wie wichtig
aufgaben reste und
verpflichtungsermächtigungen sind das
ist nämlich teilweise auch relevante
aufgaben rechte gibt und dass wir in den
bereichen eben nicht aufgeschichtet
haben sondern schauen was kann man
sinnvoll in diesem jahr noch machen das
machen wir jetzt zb im bereich digitale
schiene 400 millionen euro plus das
machen wir im bereich bahnhöfe
attraktivitätsprogramm bahnhöfe da sind
lücken gerissen wurden auf kabinetts
hatten die wir teilweise wieder gepflegt
haben weil auch das 9 euro ticket wird
uns zeigen es füllt die bahn nicht wenn
sich menschen weil sie zb auch den
rollator angewiesen sind oder auf den
rollstuhl oder weil sich am bahnhof
einfach nicht sicher fühlen nicht in
diesen zug rein gelangen deswegen noch
mal 21,5 millionen für das bonusprogramm
obendrauf wir machen als erste co
lektion im bundeshaushalt auch einen
titel für die nachtzüge ganz geschafft
dass wir dort den satz offen
koalitionsvertrag haushalterisch unter
setzen dass wir uns nämlich beteiligen
daran die voraussetzungen zu schaffen
dass es ein dichtes zuverlässiges
europäisches nachtzug netz und wir
schafften nicht zuletzt manche mögen das
als bezeichnen 30 millionen für das
format parkhaus programm weil es nicht
in den kleinsten gemeinden aber in den
großen durchaus ein problem ist dass ich
dass dieser knotenpunkt diese
verknüpfung von von radverkehr unter
anfang er einfach nicht funktioniert
weil die menschen sich nicht trauen über
nacht das rad am bahnhof stehen zu
lassen und auch das wird hier behoben
wir schaffen realität wir verändern
realitäten und wir sind uns dabei aber
natürlich bewusst dass wir nicht die
gesamten fehler von steuerung seinen
vorgänger in einem halben jahr und auch
nicht im nächsten halben jahr komplett
neutralisieren können
wir werden jetzt auch der kollege hat
ganz richtig in den raum geworfen
geworfen noch 131 millionen oben drauf
packen vielen dank auch an die gute
zusammenarbeit mit meiner kollegin 20
hier sind für den radverkehr weil wir
auch in den letzten tagen gesehen haben
dass immer noch viele menschen gerne
aufs rad umsteigen würden sich aber
nicht trauen weil sie sich nicht sicher
fühlen und genau diese sichere rat
verkehrsinfrastruktur auch da müssen
bund und länder wie in allen anderen
verkehrsbereichen noch besser
zusammenarbeiten weil wir am ende alle
davon profitieren wenn die die wollen
auch fahrrad fahren können das ist nicht
nur so dass wir damit emotionen
einsparen es ist sondern auch so dass
wir dadurch die gesamte gesellschaft
gesünder machen nicht nur die die selber
fahren sondern auch die mitmenschen die
geschützt werden durch weniger abgase
und weniger lärm wir haben jetzt in
diesem haushalt nicht alle probleme die
wir im deutschen verkehrsbereich
vorfinden gelöst das ist richtig aber
wir haben angefangen die richtigen
weichen zu stellen um die versprechen
aus dem koalitionsvertrag
die wir als ampel gegeben haben im
verkehrsbereich um die einzelnen des
neuen euro ticket ist das sichtbarste
und das spürbar zu was wir jetzt in
diesem bereich in den nächsten monaten
machen und es wird uns auch unglaublich
viele daten geben würde mich zum
beispiel in dem bereich wo ist es
tatsächlich so dass niedrige preise
allein was was ja zum beispiel auch die
linkspartei immer fordert wo es
tatsächlich so dass niedrige preise
allein heute schon reichen um den
menschen wirklich ein gutes umstiegs
angebot auf den öffentlichen nahverkehr
zu machen und wo sind die regionen wo
selbst der niedrige preis heute darf
noch nicht leisten können weil einfach
nicht genug angebot da also wir wollen
anregen könnte es schaffen dass der
verkehrspolitik in diesem land den
versprechen koalitionsvertrag gerecht
wird wir fangen damit diese an aber das
ist unsere forderung natürlich auch für
die haushalte der nächsten jahre vielen
dank
der kollege felix schreiner spricht
jetzt für die cdu csu bereit
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren in einer
haushaltsdebatte
und ein beim bundeshaushalt da wird es
dann ganz konkret man kann schwarz auf
weiß sichtbar sehen was die jeweilige
koalition vor hat was sie plant und was
sie in zukunft konkret anpacken möchte
und genau damit sind wir schon beim
problem diese koalition hat keinen plan
sie hat aber jede menge verwirrung wo
sie stiftet verwirrung in ganz
deutschland
die bundesregierung fällt ja durch dauer
streitigkeiten auf es ist eben nicht
klar ob mit den 15 millionen
elektroautos zwei bis 2030 rein batterie
geladen oder auch hybride autos gemein
sind es ist nicht klar ob bei den
verbrennungsmotoren
zukünftig auch synthetische kraftstoffe
zukunft haben wir haben wenn bis 2030
noch 30 millionen verbrenner unterwegs
sind es ist nicht klar ob ein tempolimit
kommt oder ob es jetzt ad acta gelegt
ist ob neue brücken 6 statt vierspurig
ausgebaut werden um den wachsenden
verkehrsaufkommen rechnung zu tragen und
es ist auch nicht klar was diese
koalition eigentlich macht und diesen
bundesverkehrswegeplan bis 2030 noch
schneller umzusetzen stattdessen gibt es
streit bei der a100 er in berlin oder
bei den neckar schleusen in baden
württemberg wir müssen nach sechs
monaten
ampelkoalition schlicht und ergreifend
festhalten anspruch und wirklichkeit
dieser selbsternannten fortschritts
koalition bricht meilenweit auseinander
meine damen und herren das ist die wahre
und
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wenn ich
dann höre mit dem neuen euro ticket ich
finde sie haben wirklich dem pfad der
solitäre der solidität und ja auch der
verlässlichkeit in der haushaltspolitik
wirklich verlassen ihr schnellschuss
eines neuen euro tickets wird den
steuerzahler am ende
2,5 milliarden euro und noch mehr kosten
und in wahrheit ist es einfach
handwerklich schlecht gemacht sie haben
keine kompensation für die steigenden
energie- personal- und für die baukosten
enthalten und es führt in der zweiten
runde deshalb auch zu einer verteuerung
der ticketpreise sind bei den es
gefährdet die privaten finanzierten
innovationen im verkehr und es treibt
familiengeführte betriebe schlicht und
ergreifend an den rand der insolvenz
weil sie sich doch jetzt schon von
stornierungen gar nicht mehr retten
können es ist eine maßnahme gegen den
ländlichen raum und anstatt die
voraussetzungen dafür zu schaffen dass
wir eine dichtere taktung und einen
besseren nahverkehr
gerade in den ländlichen raum haben was
nutzt denn einen neuen euro ticket wenn
der zug oder der bus gar nicht fährt
oder überfüllt ist sie verbrennen das
geld der bürger sie werfen eine
nebelkerze nach der anderen rennen die
republik und das lassen wir ihnen heute
schon gar nicht durchgehend alle
darunter
und was sie auch immer wieder
fälschlicherweise betonen diese genau
vielen dank herr schäfer jetzt sage ich
mal eines direkt die rekord
investitionen im verkehrsbereich sind
doch nicht in diesem haushalt sie sind
in wahrheit in der letzten legislatur in
diesem deutschen bundestag beschlossen
worden es war die vorgängerregierung
übrigens auch noch mit der spd die villa
immer nicht mehr dabei sein aber die
wahrheit war es war die große koalition
die für rekordinvestitionen im
investitionshaushalt im deutschen
bundestag für die verkehrspolitik in
diesem land gesorgt hat bekennen sie
sich doch mal von der spd dafür ist der
den effie besser wenn sie mal ein
bisschen fröhlicher durchs land gehen
vielleicht werden dann ihre umfragen
auch wieder besser meine damen und
herren es galt schon in der letzten
legislatur das prinzip ausbau vor erhalt
das prinzip er halver aus und neubau es
wurde erfolgreich umgesetzt
es gab ein klares bekenntnis für die
verkehrsinfrastruktur und ich möchte sie
auch wirklich dafür waren und ich mache
das immer an dieser stelle vielleicht
glauben sie es mir dann irgendwann vor
einem straßenbaum moratorium was spd und
grüne fordern sie werden dafür für eine
verzögerung sämtliche bauprojekte in
diesem land sorgen dass werden uns
jahrzehnte kosten wenn sie sich damit
gegen die fdp durchsetzen unsere
unterstützung haben sie als fdp an zur
stelle es kann doch nicht sein dass sie
in diesem haushalt ausgerechnet an
dieser stelle bei der autobahn gmbh oder
beim deutschen zentrum der mobilität so
massiv die mittel kürzen 1 gegen
wahrheit brauchen wir da einen
mittelzufluss meine damen und herren sie
hat diese haushalten traum handball
präsidentin ist kein großer wurf nein er
ist ein ausdruck der planlosigkeit
dieser ampel koalition
[Applaus]
für die bundesregierung spricht jetzt
der politik doktor volker wissing
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
spontan irgendwo
hinzufahren freunde und familie treffen
ins theater zum sport zur schule oder
zur uni gehen voran kommen im leben
ziele erreichen die welt erkunden das
ist freiheit und freiheit braucht
mobilität es ist unsere aufgabe diese
mobilität zu ermöglichen einfach
bezahlbar intelligent umwelt und
klimafreundlich
dieser leitgedanke
ermöglichen statt erschweren prägt die
verkehrspolitik dieser bundesregierung
und den haushalt den wir heute hier
beraten fast 22 milliarden euro können
wir investieren dafür danke ich ihnen
ganz herzlich unser ziel ist eine
mobilität die den unterschiedlichen
bedürfnissen der menschen gerecht wird
der familienvater der mit kindern auf
dem land lebt braucht ein anderes
mobilitätsangebot als die studentinnen
der stadt oder der rentner der aus
altersgründen nicht mehr auto fahren
möchte wo der staat lieferant braucht
andere transportlösungen als ein stück
vor hersteller unser haushaltsentwurf
trägt all dem rechnung indem wir die
schiene weiter stärken und den op en v
unterstützen wie nie zuvor den
radverkehr zu einem wichtigen element
unserer politik machen erstmals eine
nationale fuß verkehrs strategie
erarbeiten die klimafreundliche
schifffahrt fördern und natürlich auch
straßen und brücken sanieren und neu
bauen denn sie sind nun mal ganz
wichtige lebensadern unserer mobilität
vor allem aber werden wir die
digitalisierung nutzen und dafür sorgen
dass daten sicher bereitgestellt
ausgetauscht verknüpft und genutzt
werden können damit ermöglichen wir auch
ganz neue mobilitätsangebote und neue
geschäftsmodelle mit lösungen die
individuell auf die bedürfnisse der
menschen zugeschnitten sind und die den
umstieg von einem verkehrsmittel auf ein
anderes erleichtern und im alltag
anwendbar machen bahnhöfe sollen zu
attraktiven mobilitäts drehkreuzen
werden barrierefrei mit fahrrad
parkhäusern und autostellplätzen die
selbstverständlich auch mit ladesäulen
ausgestattet sind wir vernetzen die
verkehrsträger effizient und intelligenz
damit menschen zum beispiel leichter vom
rad in die straßenbahn oder vom auto in
den zug steigen können und damit waren
leichter vom lkw auf dem zug oder das
schiff verladen werden können moderne
mobilität bedeutet anzuerkennen dass
jeder verkehrsträger gebraucht wird
jeder hat seine eigenen stärken wir
müssen sie kombinieren und natürlich
massiv den umstieg auf klimafreundliche
antriebe vorantreiben deshalb machen wir
druck damit synthetische kraftstoffe
ihren beitrag zur klimaneutrale
mobilität leisten können wir machen
druck beim ausbau der ladeinfrastruktur
und wir werden den einsatz
klimafreundlicher pkw lkw nutzfahrzeuge
busse schiffe züge oder flugzeuge
erleichtern
dabei bleiben wir bewusst
technologieoffen denn nicht die politik
entscheidet am ende was ich am markt
durchsetzt sondern die verbraucherinnen
und verbraucher
sie werden sich nur dann für eine
klimafreundliche mobilität entscheiden
wenn sie darin vorteile sehen gerade
deshalb ist auch dass neun euro ticket
ein so interessantes projekt dieses
mammut vorhaben ist zwar nicht teil des
einzelplan zwölf sondern gehört zu den
regionalisierungsmitteln bund jährlich
aus dem einzelplan 60 gibt damit die
länder den nahverkehr bestellen können
in diesem jahr sind das übrigens wegen
des rettungsschirms und des neuen euro
tickets mehr als 13 milliarden euro die
der bund in ländern zur verfügung stellt
um en v zu organisieren aber unabhängig
davon ist der enorme ansturm auf das
neue euro ticket ein sehr ermutigendes
signal
es zeigt eine große zahl von menschen
sind bereit den eigenen mobilitäts
gewohnheiten auch mal etwas neues
entgegen zu stellen was neues
auszuprobieren über sieben millionen
menschen haben bereits einen neuen euro
ticket erworben das ist die abstimmung
der bürgerinnen und bürger über dieses
erfolgs
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
menschen sind offen neugierig sind
bereit für veränderungen und unsere
aufgabe ist es dafür zu sorgen dass sie
diese veränderungen als etwas positives
empfinden als fortschritt in dem wir
nichts erschweren indem wir ihnen nichts
nehmen indem wir ihnen nichts
vorschreiben sondern indem wir
ermöglichen den eigenen individuellen
bedürfnissen auch ein individuelles
mobilitätsangebot klimafreundlich
zukunftsgerichtet entgegenzustellen ich
bin überzeugt dieser haushalt macht all
das möglich und bitte deshalb um ihre
zustimmung und dann gehen
herzlichen dank
nächster redner ist der kollege dr der
spanier af die fraktion
vielen dank präsident sehr geehrte
kollegen nie gab es mehr zu tun der
minister sie werden sich erinnern das
war das logo für das fdp wahlprogramm
zur letzten bundestagswahl beschlossen
ziemlich genau vor einem jahr im mai
sie erinnern sich doch sicher daran oder
vielleicht doch nicht ich helfe ihnen
gerne ein pauschales verbot von
verbrennungsmotoren lehnte die fdp
damals ab nach meinen informationen wird
die fdp jetzt auf europäischer ebene
sich nicht gegen das verbot von
verbrennungsmotoren stellen und damit
befürworten sie dass sie können wir
gerne wieder sprechen und das hier
klarstellen aber ich habe die
informationen dass sie sich dann nicht
gegen stellen werden weiterer punkt sie
haben versprochen die
schieneninfrastruktur und den
bahnbetrieb zu trennen davon höre ich
jetzt gar nichts mehr planungsverfahren
sollten beschleunigt werden ich erinnere
mich an die diskussion im
verkehrsausschuss kann nicht sehen dass
das irgendwas in die richtung passiert
und die luftverkehrsteuer wollten sie
auch abschaffen all das
ist nicht passiert
noch nie wurde die verlässlichkeit eines
wahlprogramms und regierungshandeln so
auf den kopf gestellt wie durch ihre fdp
herr dr wiz
die fdp hat ihren verkehrspolitischen
kurs von 180 grad geändert hat geben sie
in dieser koalition ist wir übrigens
nicht und anbietern dann den grünen
zeitgeist rühmen sie sich im vorwort zum
verkehrs etat wird mehr geld in die
schiene investiert als in die straße das
ist richtig aber um auf die 12,8
milliarden für die schienenwege zu
kommen die sie hier zitieren da rechnet
sich noch die eigenkapitalerhöhung der
deutschen bahn ag in höhe von ungefähr
einer milliarde hinzu das ist nichts
anderes als ein taschenspielertrick die
db ag ist nämlich ein international
aufgestelltes unternehmen ein
logistikunternehmen und sie
subventionieren anhaltendes
missmanagement bei der bahn sie geben
deutsches steuergeld für neue busse in
großbritannien aus oder für schenker
lkws in italien und erzählen den
menschen das käme den deutschen
schienennetz zu gute das einzige was
konsequent bei der bahn steigt das ist
die verspätung squaw die unternehmens
verschuldung und die vergütung der
vorstände und dank einer spd-mann beiden
gewerkschaft erhalten die
bahnbeschäftigten 15 prozent mehr gehalt
sie vergessen aber zu erwähnen dass die
vorstände satte zehn prozent mehr
kriegen so was nehmen sie dann vorrang
für die schiene und gebetsmühlenhaft
beschwört die ampel koalition mehr
verkehr auf die schiene bringen zu
wollen
wo leben sie eigentlich das deutsche
schienennetz dicht da geht nichts mehr
die pünktlichkeit im fernverkehr liegt
bei unter 70 prozent ihr mantra von der
verlagerung auf die schiene ist eine
realitätsferne märchen der lkw ist und
bleibt das wichtigste transportmittel
auch perspektivisch was sagen sogar
aktuelle studien auch vom
umweltbundesamt
und der haushalt sieht vor dass rund
11,4 milliarden euro für bau und
erhaltung der bundesfernstraßen
investiert werden dass es angesichts des
jahrelangen sanierungsstaus wohl auch
bitter notwendig der bundesminister für
klima hysterie und gesinnung stehen
heute schon die grünen nehmen sie bitte
häufiger ihr wahlprogramm zur hand
aktuell können wir nur feststellen sie
sind gelebter vertrauensverlust
und für alle die bessere straßen eine
funktionierende bahn eine abschaffung
der luftverkehrsteuer und auch einen
funktionierenden schiffsverkehr wollen
für die gibt es ja eine politische
alternative für deutschland vielen dank
vielen dank herr kollege
als nächstes werde er das wort die
kollegin bettina hagedorn spd
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen
wir haben ja dieser debatte schon viel
gehört richtigerweise darüber auch von
ihnen herr minister dass sie der bahn
und der schiene eine priorität einräumen
wollen gegenüber den straßen das
stichwort das allerdings noch fehlt ist
der ausbau der wasserstraßen dem der
kopf endlich dem kommt nämlich genau so
eine hohe priorität zu vereinen wenn wir
auf europäischer ebene schon seit zehn
jahren davon reden dass güterverkehre
von der schiene und von der straße auf
die schiene und auch die wasserwege
verlagert werden sollen und darum bin
ich meiner fraktion dankbar dass ich
hier zu einem ganz besonders wichtigen
wasserweg sprechen darf denn seit über
zehn jahren verfolgt insbesondere der
haushaltsausschuss des deutschen
bundestages das ziel den kommt den
nord-ostsee-kanal einer
grundinstandsetzung
durchzuführen
in dem bericht den ich im
haushaltsausschuss von ihnen angefordert
hatte der leider nicht sehr
aussagekräftig ist aber sie haben schon
zugesagt die nachzubessern dafür bin ich
ihnen sehr dankbar in diesem bericht die
dritte stünden zweieinhalb milliarden
euro zur verfügung und das stimmt die
wahrheit ist aber dass nicht ein center
von das verkehrsministerium beim
finanzministerium durchgeboxt hat
sondern in fünf bereinigungssitzung des
deutschen bundestages wurde das
beschlossen zweieinhalb milliarden
insgesamt nun hört sich das nach einer
erfolgsstory anders ist aber nicht ganz
so denn 20 21 so steht es in ihrem
bericht waren 250 millionen euro
ausgegeben das sind genau zehn prozent
und die sind ganz überwiegend in der
fünften schleusenkammer genannte die
hier 20 26 fertig werden soll
ursprünglich sollte sie ja mal 20 1820
21 25 24 fertig werden womit wir bei dem
thema planungs beschleunigung auf das
ich eingehen möchte weil bei diesem
thema planungs beschleunigung von vielen
in diesem haus gerne so getan wird als
sei es immer die bürgerinitiativen und
die umweltverbände die dem schnellen
baufortschritt im wege stehen würden
aber der nord ostsee kanal ist ein gutes
beispiel dafür
dort hat es mir nicht die
bürgerinitiativen gegeben die irgendein
bauabschnitt im wege gestanden haben und
die umweltverbände auch nicht das hat
die wasser und schifffahrtsverwaltung
und das verkehrsministerium unter drei
csu verkehrsministern ganz alleine
geschafft
ja das ist leider traurig dass sie dazu
beifall klatschen müssen es ist eine
pointe aber es ist die traurige wahrheit
und darum will ich darauf eingehen herr
minister was auch in diesem bericht
leider nicht steht obwohl ich danach
gefragt hatte das sind nämlich die
anderen bauabschnitte wie für den kanal
genauso wichtig sind wie die fünfte
schleusenkammer und deren baufortschritt
gar nichts mit dieser fünften
schleusenkammer in brunsbüttel zu tun
hat das ist vor einigen wie ost strecke
der ausbau der ice-strecke zwischen
rendsburg und kiel war 2014 mal mit 130
millionen veranschlagt jetzt mit 500
millionen 2010 und wissen sie was in
ihrem bericht steht
in dem bericht steht der bau der
baufortschritt des zweiten
bauabschnittes ist abhängig von zur
verfügung stehenden haushaltsmitteln so
steht es bei allen anderen
bauabschnitten nach denen ich gefragt
hatte das heißt die zweieinhalb
milliarden wo sind sie nur fakt ist der
zweite bauabschnitt da ist bisher nur
die planung ausgeschrieben leider ist
meine redezeit zu ende der
nord-ostsee-kanal wäre ein abendessen
abendfüllendes thema und ich hatte
richtig viel spaß daran offen darüber
auch mal einen solchen abend zu machen
vielen dank
diese regelmäßig kollege ankündung
scheint berg fraktion die linke
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter präsident liebe
kolleginnen als digital experten gucke
ich natürlich nicht nur auf die inhalte
im koalitionsvertrag sondern auch auf
die umsetzung und da kommen wir jetzt
schon die tränen eine
digitalisierungsstrategie fehlt nach wie
vor die governance zur digitalisierung
ist ein reiner albtraum niemand blickt
durch wer hat für was die federführung
zuständigkeiten sind doppelt dreifach
oder überhaupt nicht verteilt und nach
25 wochen im amt liegt das von mir schon
vor monaten anbieten wimmelbild der
digitalisierungs zuständigkeiten
immerhin immer noch nicht vor das ist
schlampige regierungsarbeit das ist
keine ampel das ist eine [ __ ] meine
damen und herren
haushaltsmittel im koalition zum
koalitionsvertrag passen auch nicht
zusammen versprochen waren unter anderem
nachhaltigkeit und ein recht auf
schnelles internet
es gibt ein eigenes referat für
nachhaltigkeit und digitalisierung mb im
dvs hat genau null haushaltsmittel es
koordiniert ja nur schrieb man mir und
jahr fördermittel könnten die datenlage
verbessern und innovationen anreizen im
haushalt gibt es aber trotzdem keine
dafür danke für mich zwei minister
statt recht auf schnelles internet kommt
ein recht auf dass lahms mögliche
internet 10 mbit download und 1,7 mbit
upload geschwindigkeit und selbst dieser
mickrige rechtsanspruch kommt nicht wie
versprochen zum 16 noch wirkt er wie
versprochen kurzfristig dann von der
beschwerde bis zum lahms möglichen
internet dauert es bis zu 14 monate oder
auch länger denn im haushalt der
bundesnetzagentur hat minister deswegen
den personalaufwand für die bearbeitung
der etwa 300.000 der
anspruchsberechtigten haushalte einfach
vergessen what the [ __ ]
dieses fdp ministerium schafft keine
sicherstellung einer angemessenen
internet mindestversorgung weder durch
bandbreiten die auf einer familie
grundversorgung ermöglichen noch durch
personal bei der bnetza und auch nicht
durch die förderung eines kommunalen
glasfaserausbaus ohne zwangsverkauft der
glasfasernetz an den markt es handelt
nach der maxime markt first bürger innen
und klima second das muss sich ändern
und dafür wird die linksfraktion
weiterkämpfen vielen dank
vielen dank von
lilien domscheit-berg nächster werden
erste kollege mike ausgekauft bin ich 90
die grünen
[Applaus]
der präsidenten der kolleginnen und
kollegen frau domscheit-berg sie haben
da gerade das vermeintliche recht auf
schnelles internet angesprochen sie
wissen auch ganz genau das ist nicht das
recht auf das internet das ist der
universaldienst schon heute haben über
90 prozent der haushalte in deutschland
mehr als 100 mbit diesen universaldienst
ihren sie ansprechen da ist genau für
die menschen gedacht die noch
unterversorgt sind damit einen
mindestanspruch haben und das ist auch
nur eine interimslösung unser ziel sind
100 mbit mindestens und glasfaser in
allen deutschen haushalten mittelfristig
und sie reden hier von einer
interimslösung
meine damen und herren
digitalisierung ist ein
querschnittsthema dass alle bereiche des
sozialen politischen und
wirtschaftlichen lebens durchdringend
und so sind die digital posten auch über
die verschiedenen ministerien verteilt
und wir sprechen über mehrere
einzelpläne wenn wir digitalisierung als
ganzes betrachten und es stimmt die
eingebrachten einzelpläne waren in
einigen bereichen hinter den erwartungen
zurückgeblieben und sind nicht den
ansprüchen an eine sozial digitale und
ökologischere form gerecht geworden und
deswegen an dieser stelle zunächst mal
mein großer dank an unsere
haushälterinnen die parlamentarischen
weg ihren mehreren plänen und in den
intensiver zusammenarbeiten und
politikerinnen gute nachbesserungen
verhandelt haben
ich komme noch mal zurück zum
breitbandausbau wie gesagt das ziel ist
100% glasfaser versorgung und wir haben
nicht erst in der pandemie gemerkt wie
wichtig der schnelle breitband ausbau
ist dass es für die teilhabe der
menschen im land natürlich auch für die
wirtschaft eine grundversorgung ist und
deswegen jetzt ja auch darum zum teil
mit großem mitteln aus der
privatwirtschaft voranzukommen das ist
natürlich da der großteil gleichzeitig
aber auch die förderung aus aufrecht zu
erhalten und den ausbau zu verstetigen
denn nur so kommen wir in die fläche an
jedes haus und an jeder milchkanne
aus dem gmbh sind hier knapp 80
millionen vorgesehen der großteil
allerdings kommt für den breitband und
mobilfunk ausbau mit etwa zweieinhalb
milliarden euro aus dem sondervermögen
digitale infrastruktur falls sie da in
den einzelplänen nicht fündig geworden
sind da ist genug geld vorhanden am geld
scheitert nicht
im mobilfunk bereich müssen wir zunächst
die steuer altlasten aufräumen und jaja
osten an sie gerichtet sie haben da eben
das bild des verkatert benutzt und wenn
ich an das denke was die jeden tag an
ein scheues altlasten aufräumen müssen
da bin ich fahrkarte der wohlig bei der
sause nicht dabei sein durfte
na ja zb die mobilfunkinfrastruktur
gesellschaft gegründet das ist das
funkloch amt von herrn steuer weil der
vorjahr die vergabeverfahren für den
mobilfunk ausbau völlig verkorkst hat so
und jetzt hat der bundesrechnungshof
festgestellt das ist völlig
unwirtschaftlich was da gemacht wird da
müssen wir erst mal aufräumen und an der
stelle das muss man auch mal sagen wir
auch mittel gekürzt und zwar auf 20
millionen euro halbiert weil wir das amt
doch umstrukturieren müssen so
andererseits stecken wir aber in die
umsetzung der 5 x 5 g strategie 103
millionen euro gegenüber 16 millionen
euro im vorjahr sohn aus diesen mitteln
werden zum beispiel auch strukturwandel
in der lausitz 5g modellregion
finanziert
wir wollen aber auch weiterkommen mit
dem breitbandausbau das ist nicht nur am
geld sondern es sind die
mangelnden kapazitäten im tiefbau und
deswegen wollen wir auch alternative
verleger techniken fördern cluster
folgen neu strukturieren neue und
bessere mobilfunkversorgung an
bahnstrecken umsetzen das alles sind
punkte die in der digital strategy
gigabit strategie schon festgehalten
sind daran werden wir weiter arbeiten
ich möchte möchte jetzt hier aber auch
noch kurz auf einige ausgewählte
projekte aus anderen häusern eingehen um
das digital politische bild abzurunden
ein großer erfolg unserer haushälterin
war die nachverhandlungen im bmw car zum
server renntech fand sie haben jetzt
dreieinhalb millionen euro das ist ein
guter anfang das wird auch noch mehr
werden und mit diesem förderprogramm
liefern wir die die antwort auf ein
altbekanntes problem bei der open source
förderung denn viele nutzerinnen und
firmen nutzen open source aber es liegt
oft an einzelnen entwicklern die daran
arbeiten und mit dem service pack wollen
wir das verstetigen das muss auch noch
mehr werden und das tun wir auch
gibt es auch einen topf der ist neu
eingerichtet habe ich für das tennis das
zentrum für digitale souveränität auch
das ist ein ansatz um open source zu
fördern und zwar insbesondere für den
einsatz in staatlichen stellen
ebenfalls angesprochen bei eben 500
wissen dass daten institut wir wollen
hier ein grundstein legen um die ganzen
daten schätze die in verschiedenen
unternehmen und organisationen
schlummern zu heben wobei persönliche
daten sicher und transparent
anonymisiert werden die
staatsfinanzierung von 1,7 millionen
euro ist hier ein erster schritt und da
kommen wir gut voran
so ich komme langsam zum schluss denn
ganz wichtig ist ein thema cyber
security das habe ich nicht nur meine
eigenen erfahrungen als unternehmer
erlebt sondern gibt es im bitkom studie
hat herausgefunden dass in den letzten
jahren 88 prozent der befragten
unternehmen unter it-angriffen leiden
mussten und dabei über 200 milliarden
euro schaden eingefahren haben und da
ist es ganz wichtig dass der staat
reagiert da werden wir auch noch in
anderem kontext überreden müssen aber
hier haben wir auch förderungen bereit
gestellt 120 millionen euro alleine über
das programm digital jetzt ich komme zum
schluss mit diesem haushalt sind die
weichen richtung digitalisierung
gestellt und wir werden in den nächsten
jahren noch mehr fahrt auf nicht
frustriert
kollegin nadine schön
sehr geehrter herr präsident lieber
kollegen kollegen heraußen dorf ich bin
ihnen dankbar dass wenigstens ein redner
der koalition noch weiß dass dieses haus
auch für digitalisierung zuständig ist
in der rede des ministers hat das thema
leider komplett gefehlt und deshalb
frage ich mich herr minister wissen
warum haben sie ihr haus umbenannt das
thema digitalisierung nach vorne
gestellt warum hat die fdp immer den
großen digital politischen
entfesselung gefordert wenn sie hier in
ihrer zeit als minister nichts davon
vorlegen
ich kann das bei der letzten
haushaltsrede schon enttäuschend da
waren es 20 prozent der räte diese
fertige tarnung digitalisierung
verwendet haben jetzt haben sie
überhaupt nichts zur digitalisierung
sagt wenn man sich mal die homepage des
ministeriums anschaut dann muss man die
digitalen themen mit der lupe suchen und
auch in der öffentlichkeit habe ich ganz
viel über das neue euro ticket gehört
und über die bahn und die schiene und
weiß der geier aber zum thema
digitalisierung fast nichts dabei hat es
ganz viele gelegenheiten gegeben ich
nenne nur einmal das thema digital
minister sei schon bei sieben großer
aufschlag die g7 digital minister waren
hier in düsseldorf
es wäre eine tolle chance gewesen
darüber zu reden wie die g7 gemeinsam
ihre digitale dessen stärken wie wir
entlang der digitalen lieferketten
besser zusammenarbeiten wie wir
gemeinsam das thema cyber abwehr im
digitalen raum organisieren was für
digital ministertreffen übrig bleibt ist
vor allem die frage wie viel energie man
braucht um einen essens foto hochzuladen
und das ist entschieden zu wenig
sie sind mit viel elan beim thema
gigabit ausbau gestartet und da gab es
einige vorschusslorbeeren etwa das
bitkom der gesagt hat das ist jetzt die
chance bis 20 25 gigawatt auszubauen im
koalitionsvertrag glasfaser in jedes
haus das schaffen wir jetzt in den
letzten tagen hat man viel gehört über
streitigkeiten zwischen den
verhandlungspartnern die wand sich in
vielem uneinig aber in einem punkt waren
sich einig dass nämlich das digital
ministerium viel zu wenig macht um zu
einer konsistenten digitalstrategie und
einigkeit zwischen den partnern zu
kommen
und auch beim thema hat
digitalisierungsstrategie und digital
budget warten wir noch auf konkrete
ergebnisse
laut domscheit-berg hat schon
angesprochen der minister hatte dem
ausschuss im januar ton ein wimmelbild
versprochen mit den zuständigkeiten
wofür es er zuständig für die anderen
minister wo es schnittstellen wie lebt
man die auf wir warten immer noch darauf
wir wurden mal zu mal zu mal vertröstet
es ist jetzt morgen juni und wir haben
immer noch keine übersicht über die
zuständigkeiten wer in dieser regierung
welche digitalen themen bearbeitet
das ist unglaublich da gebe ich völlig
wäscht und leiter merkt man das eben
auch an der konkreten politik frau
kollegin hoppermann hat einen antrag
vorbereitet weil wir sie unterstützen
wollten ein gemeinsames digitalisierungs
budget schon mal als stadt der mode
abgelehnt von den koalitionsfraktionen
im haushaltsausschuss und auch im
digital ausschuss naja dann warten wir
halt noch ein jahr auf dem
digitalisierungsbericht dann kriegen wir
20 24 1 es wäre aber schön wenn wir dann
im nächsten jahr wenigstens einen fetten
denn budget heißt auch dass man
gemeinsam steuert das man standards
verein dass man gemeinsam das
controlling hat und dass man so
digitalisierungs politik gemeinsam voran
treibt und sie haben gesagt dass wir in
der letzten bundesregierung nicht
ausreichend wird das bundeskanzleramt
gelaufen ist das mag ja sein aber gar
keine koordinierung und gar keine
steuerung ist noch viel weniger und
deshalb hoffe ich sehr dass sie im laufe
des jahres bei den zuständigkeiten bei
der strategie und auch beim budget
fakten schaffen und in die umsetzung
kommen und der kollege ausgesorgt
hat jetzt gesagt was jetzt alles an
fortschritten kommt hausen doch das
waren genau die punkte die wir in der
letzten bundesregierung angefangen haben
das zentrum für digitale souveränität
den selben tag fand als die punkte haben
wir
vorbereitet die waren so dass man sie
nur noch weiter führen musste und diese
bundesregierung hat das erst mal alles
aus dem haushalt gestrichen
erst nach großer gegenwehr der ganzen
open source community wurden die jetzt
wieder eingestellt dank des parlamentes
vielen dank liebe kollegen kollegen aber
das ist doch das mindeste was an digital
politischem aufbruch kommen muss dass
sie das weiterführen was schon
vorbereitet war ehrlicherweise unter
vollschutz koalition hätte ich mir ein
bisschen mehr vorgestellt es ist jetzt
das erste halbe jahr sie haben noch die
chance gas zu geben damit das digital
ministerium auch seinem namen gerecht
wird und dich nur im verkehrs- sondern
auch den ein digital ministerium ist
vielen dank
so schön und
jetzt erhält das wort herr kollege bernd
reuther fdp fraktion
herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen es ist
nicht gut bestellt um die infrastruktur
in diesem land auch im vergleich zu
unseren europäischen
nachbarstaaten egal wo man hinschaut
schienenwege brücken schleusen viele in
einem katastrophalen zustand
und dann muss man auch mal fragen dürfen
lieber kollege oz nach lieber kollege
schreiner wer hat denn die letzten
vielen jahren verantwortung getragen wie
die verkehrsinfrastruktur in diesem land
wer war das denn das war noch sie und
sie haben das trefflich vernachlässigt
diese
koalition wird
investieren bauern erneuern sanieren in
die schiene weil wir brauchen massive
investitionen ins netz denn nur wenn die
züge pünktlich kommen steigen die
menschen in diesem land auch umsteigen
vom auto in den zug das ist ein ganz
wichtiger punkt gleiches gilt im übrigen
für die verladende wirtschaft die wollen
mehr güter auf die schiene bringen sie
können es aber nicht weil aktuell die
kapazitäten fehlen das werden wir ändern
genauso wie bei den rücken wir werden
mehrere hundert rücken jedes jahr neu
bauen in diesem land wir werden in
schleusen bei den wasserstraßen
investieren nicht nur in wulsbüttel
kollegin hagedorn sondern zb auch im
westdeutschen kanalnetz weil bei der
binnenschifffahrt da gibt es noch
kapazitäten in diesem land die wollen
wir nutzen und während bei den punkten
die ich gerade angesprochen habe es eher
um erneuerung und sanierung gibt werden
wir die ladeinfrastruktur
massiv ausbauen neu bauen weil nur so
gelingt der umstieg auf batterie
elektrisches fahren liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
und wir werden dabei bei 1 punkten die
geschwindigkeit bei planen bauen beim
ausbauen und erneuern deutlich erhöhen
das ist ein zentrales ziel dieser
koalition und der bundesregierung wir
haben da in diesem haushalt mit begonnen
wir werden das im
23er haushalt fortführen da können sie
sicher sein auch liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der union und ich habe mir
den europäischen vergleich angesprochen
sowie der fc bundestag bereits
europäische spitze ist müssen wir das
auch der verkehrsinfrastruktur auf
werden herzlichen dank
ich hatte erfahren dass ich nicht
mitgespielt
nicht der nächste rednerin ist die
kollegin war lenker auf die fraktion mit
ihrer ersten parlaments
herr präsident
sehr verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
ich will heute mit ihnen eine reise ins
baltikum unternehmen angenommen ich habe
eine panne und bleibe mit dem auto im
ländlichen litauen oder an der
lettischen ostseeküste liegen dann hätte
ich nicht nur einen fabelhaften handy
empfangen sondern auch über schnelles
internet
ich könnte mir einen abschleppwagen cap
buchen und bis der ankommt nämlich noch
an einer sohn konferenz teil wie würde
das wohl in den unterschiedlichen
ländlichen regionen deutschlands
aussehen schlimmstenfalls könnte ich
wegen schlechten empfang noch nicht mal
einen abschleppdienst anrufen im
gegensatz
zu den baltischen staaten wo man fast
alles digital erledigen kann und wo über
80 prozent der haushalte schnelles
internet haben befinden wir uns hier in
deutschland im digitalen mittelalter
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren im
koalitionsvertrag der ampel steht die
digitalisierung an vorderster stelle die
ampel hantiert ab seite 15 mit gut
klingen den schlagworten digitaler
aufbruch digitale verwaltung digitale
gesellschaft digitale wirtschaft und
digitale souveränität das klingt doch
wunderbar allerdings
die im koalitionsvertrag angekündigten
maßnahmen werden nur ungenügend
umgesetzt
deutschland tritt bei der
digitalisierung auf der stelle
die internetgeschwindigkeit im breitband
liegt in deutschland mit
durchschnittswerten zwischen 25 und 29
megabit pro sekunde im europäischen
mittel das skandinavische und baltische
länder erreichen werte bist du
sagenhafte fünf und 50 megabit pro
sekunde
aber schauen wir wieder nach deutschland
beispielsweise werden gut 37 5 millionen
euro zusätzlich für die stärkung der
digitalen souveränität ausgegeben
grundsätzlich gilt die erhöhung der
ausgaben für digitales sind richtig und
gut und sie sind auch dringend notwendig
angesichts des rückstandes den wir in
deutschland bei der digitalisierung
haben
aber sie reichen bei weitem nicht aus
wir haben immer noch keinen
einheitlichen digitalen haushalt und
immer noch kein digitalen ministerium
wird herr kollege offener schon gesagt
hat die bundesregierung ist mit ihren
digital politischen vorhaben als tiger
gesprungen und als bettvorleger zu
landen
deutschland ein hoch industrialisiertes
land steht bei der digitalisierung
schlechter da als unsere nachbarn die
bundesregierung so schreibt es der
tagesspiegel hat ein paar millionen für
die digitalisierung
zusammengekratzt sehr verehrte damen und
herren sehr geehrter herr minister wenn
wir nicht bald umgesteuert wird
verspielen wir die zukunft unseres
landes und der kommenden generation
vielen dank
[Applaus]
herzlichst hat das wort die kollegin
dorothee martin spd-fraktion
kollegin kollegen meine damen und herren
zunächst möchte ich meinen kolleginnen
kollegen den teams in allen die diesen
etat mitgestaltet haben ganz herzlich
danken für ihre arbeit was haben wir den
gemeinsam erreicht wir haben eine
wichtige erste etappe zur realisierung
der ziele unseres koalitionsvertrags
erreicht nämlich eine nachhaltige eine
vernetzte eine innovative und eine
bezahlbare mobilität umzusetzen
ja und auch mit einem neuen euro ticket
dass gerade viele menschen mit schmalem
geldbeutel wirklich entlastet aber die
haben sie wirklich aus den blick
genommen cdu und csu
mit einer deutlich höheren
geschwindigkeit für die dekarbonisierung
des verkehrs sorgen und zugleich angehen
dass mobilität noch besser für alle
zugänglich ist denn mobilität ist eben
auch daseinsvorsorge und das für die
menschen in der stadt aber eben auch im
ländlichen raum liebe kolleginnen
kollegen das alles das ist ein prozess
ja der kann nicht von heute auf morgen
umgesetzt werden dass das glaube ich
klar aber ich bin davon überzeugt wenn
wir die kapazität nicht mehr für
unsinnige projekte wie eine pkw-maut für
ausländer verbrauchen dann werden wir
auch bei zielen im verkehr deutlich
besser vorankommen während sie doch in
vergangenheitsbewältigung feststecken
das haben wir heute gehört
die willigen mittel anhörung für
bundeswasserstraßen für
binnenschifffahrt für radverkehr
förderung attraktivitätssteigerung
barrierefreiheit von bahnhöfen das sind
richtig gute und wichtige entscheidungen
das gilt auch für den kombinierten
verkehr
denn gerade für das erreichen des
verkehrs und umweltpolitische ziel mehr
güter von der straße auf die schiene zu
bekommen spielt eben der kombinierte
verkehr eine ganz große eine immer
wichtigere rolle daher begrüßen wir sehr
dass diese in den haushaltsverhandlungen
weiter gestärkt wurde und was uns auch
besonders freut dass der fuß verkehr als
doch die grundlegendste alle
verkehrsarten jetzt erstmals mit einem
eigenen haushalten jahr und hier eben
deutschen bundestag da diskutieren die
abgeordneten momentan über den
einzelplan 12 das ist der einzelplan des
ministeriums für digitales und verkehr
von bundesminister volker wissing
36,1 milliarden euro stehen ihm zur
verfügung der haushaltsausschuss hat in
seiner bereinigungssitzung
vergangene woche diesen etat noch einmal
erhöht um
111 millionen euro so dass es jetzt auf
die 36,1 milliarden euro kommt denn es
ist auch viel zu tun es gibt zb einen
masterplan schienenverkehr mit dem die
bundesregierung die verkehrsleistung im
personenverkehr verdoppeln möchte
und zum beispiel
gleise erneuern will weichen müssen
erneuert werden brücken und auch
bahnhöfe sollen in der nächsten zeit
verbessert werden und
benutzerfreundlicher gemacht werden denn
auch das ist ein ziel der so genannte
deutschland takt das soll eingesetzt
werden was ist der deutschland pakt das
bedeutet dass die züge auf den
hauptachsen im halbstündlichen rhythmus
fahren und alle anderen anschlüsse
daraufhin optimiert und verstärkt werden
allerdings gibt es schon kritik dass
auch das geld das nun dafür anvisiert
ist nicht reichen wird das wird sich in
zukunft zeigen und natürlich wird wohl
auch in dieser debatte immer wieder das
thema 9 euro ticket zur sprache kommen
ab morgen gilt es ja schon ein
vierteljahr für jeweils 9 euro pro monat
können die bürgerinnen und bürger mit
dem öffentlichen nahverkehr in ganz
deutschland fahren dafür gab es hier
schon viel lob von den
koalitionsfraktionen und so kann man es
ein konto mannes erwarten kritik von der
opposition
und wir schauen jetzt dann in die
debatte rein für die grünen spricht
jetzt als nächstes matthias gastel er
sitzt auch im verkehrsausschuss
[Applaus]
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen der handlungsbedarf ist gerade
im bereich der schienenwege der
schienenwege infrastruktur besonders
groß wir erleben derzeit aktuell massive
verspätungen im bahnverkehr
es wird zu wenig investiert in die
infrastruktur aber die deutsche bahn ist
noch nicht mal in der lage dieses geld
vollständig abzurufen und zu verbauen
und deren
baustellenmanagement ist sehr
kritikwürdig die kapazität ist so
niedrig auch durch die vielen baustellen
die nicht gut gemanagt werden und
gestern hat der db-chef sogar verkündet
dass güter teilweise wieder auf die
straße wandern müssten weil die
kapazitäten auf der schiene nicht
ausreichen dass meine damen und herren
das ist die folge von drei völlig
verkehrten bundesverkehrsminister und
drei verkehrsministern in folge die von
der csu kamen drei unions
bundesverkehrsminister waren einfach zu
viel für das deutsche schienennetz das
verkraftet es nicht sie an ein einziges
politisches trümmerfeld hinterlassen
der haushalt
2022 der haushalt 2022 ist sicherlich
nicht genug und schon gar nicht genug um
alle probleme aufzulösen aber er enthält
doch einige positive botschaften
beispielsweise steigen die bedarfsplan
mittel für den aus und neubau der
schiene gegenüber 20 21 um 22 prozent
die lärms sanierungsmittel steigen an um
33 prozent und für die elektrische
güterbahn gibt es 24 prozent mehr als
noch im vorjahr die investitionen in die
schieneninfrastruktur steigen gegenüber
20 21 insgesamt um 180 millionen euro
die investitionen in die schiene league
um 970 millionen euro höher als die in
die straße wobei muss man leichter zu
sagen wir müssen mal darüber reden was
da alles jeweils rein gerechnet wird das
müssen wir mal noch machen aber der weg
der kurs den wir einschlagen der stimmt
auf jeden fall
7,4 milliarden euro stehen zur verfügung
ein
verpflichtungsermächtigungen das heißt
finanzierungssicherheit für die
infrastruktur in den folgejahren und ich
freue mich ganz besonders als ein fan
der nach züge dass es hier vorangeht
dass wir an einem europäischen nacht zu
konzept arbeiten und hier die schiene
attraktiver machen gegenüber dem
flugverkehr
im haushalt 2023 wird die koalition
dafür sorgen müssen den
koalitionsvertrag noch mal deutlich
stärker abbilden abzubilden als es jetzt
gelungen ist in stichworten es geht um
die bahnhöfe die engpassbeseitigung im
netz es geht um die gleisanschlüsse für
industriebetriebe da muss der
verkehrsminister die förderrichtlinie
auch mal vorlegen und es geht um
klarheit darüber dass es dauerhaft
niedrigere trassenpreise insbesondere
für den güterverkehr gibt
anders
anders als mit mehr geld für die schiene
lassen sich die klimaziele im
verkehrsbereich nicht erreichen wir
haben also viel zu tun da 22 der
haushalt ist ein anfang aber wir sind da
noch nicht weit genug da muss dann 23
deutlich mehr geliefert werden
insbesondere deutlich mehr mittel für
die schiene gegenüber der strasse wir
brauchen eine zweite schiene im
personenverkehr damit mehr leute statt
mit dem auto mit einer zuverlässigen
bahnverkehr
berichte auf die schiene verlagert
werden können so erreichen wir eine
bessere gesündere mobilität und
erreichen auch die klimaziele im verkehr
matthias gastel war das für bündnis
90/die grünen der hier natürlich auch
auf der klimaziele eingegangen ist
selbstverständlich gehört dass auch dazu
wenn über den schienenverkehr gesprochen
wird ulrich lange stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender der unionsfraktion
spricht als nächstes
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen es ist der erste
verkehrshaushalt der neuen
bundesregierung und ersetzt lieber
kollege gastel sichtbar auf dem auf was
die alte bundesregierung in den letzten
jahren erfolgreich gestartet hat
investitions hochlauf für die straße für
die schiene für den radverkehr das war
gelebte unions verkehrspolitik mit den
kolleginnen und kollegen der spd ihr
dürft gerne mit lassen das haben wir
zusammen geleistet
und wenn ich dann dem koalitionsvertrag
lese dann würdigen sie ja selber die
eigene arbeit die verkehrsmittel in die
verkehrsinfrastruktur
müssen weiter erhöht werden nachdem drei
csu verkehrsminister jahr für jahr mehr
geld organisiert haben viel erfolg
lieber kollege wissen bei ihrem
finanzminister auch da mehr zu bekommen
das haben sie erkannt den
deutschlandpakt wollen sie stärken den
masterplan
schienengüterverkehr wollen sie
vorantreiben das ist alles richtig nur
die
haushaltswahrheit ist natürlich
ernüchterung liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen warum
sie senken die mittel beim programm
zukunft schienengüterverkehr sie senken
die mittel bei neu- und ausbau sie
senken sogar die mittel bei den gleichen
schlüssen lieber kollege gastel das was
sie hier gerade so groß
vorgetragen haben kraut natürlich in der
lebenswirklichkeit anders aus
stattdessen reden sie über 400 millionen
für die digitalisierung der 4 die finden
natürlich nicht im haushalt 20
22 grad sondern die finden in ganz
ferner zukunft wird und wissen sie warum
sie haben ja sicher sehr mir sicher das
interview des bahnchefs lutz gestern
gelesen was hat er denn zur
digitalisierung der schiene gesagt ich
denke da wird auch der verkehrsminister
ein bisschen hellhörig geworden sein
wenn ich eine störanfällige
infrastruktur
digitalisierung bleibt es eine
störanfällige
infrastruktur so nutz und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen also also
setzten sie doch nicht hier etwas in die
welt was nicht funktioniert vielmehr
setzten sie dort an wo wir begonnen
haben schritt für schritt sanieren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und lieber kollege gastel der kollege
kinder 20 20 3,7 milliarden lieber
kollege per ivans 3,7 milliarden
jährliche jährlich gefordert der kollege
lutz hat gefordert dass es nicht mehr
staatskonzern sein darf und lieber
verkehrsminister wissing genau auf diese
fragen fehlen aber in diesem haushalt
ihre antworten groß gestartet wenig
gekommen und wenn sie
und wenn sie übers geld reden und die
sanierung reden wir haben die leistungs
und finanzierungsvereinbarung
deutlich erhöht 8,6 milliarden 8,6
milliarden jährlich nur die bahn schafft
es nicht die brücken zu sanieren sie
schafft es nicht in barrierefreien
ausbau darzustellen nein all das auch
wenn der bahnhof mit 60 milliarden
zusätzlich fordern ich kenne von der db
immer nur die forderung nach geld ich
möchte jetzt jedoch taten sehen für das
geld das bereitgestellt ist liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und 2,5
milliarden euro für das
2,5 milliarden euro für das 9 euro
ticket das sind
250 barrierefreie bahnhöfe nach unserem
zip programm kann ich schlecht halte ich
das würde ich ihnen empfehlen wir sind
anwalt der bürgerinnen und bürger wir
sind an walter mobilität für schiene und
straße dankeschön
ulrich langer war das für die
unionsfraktion ein teil der bahn
modernisierung ist auch die
digitalisierung der bahn aber auch die
digitalisierung insgesamt ist natürlich
thema in diesem einzelplan jens
zimmermann der nächste redner ist der
digital politische sprecher der
sozialdemokraten
den haushalt des bundesministeriums für
digitales und verkehr aber man muss
natürlich einen tag herr kollege ich
drück wirklich die daumen dass herr
pofalla das hinbekommt mit der
infrastruktur bei der fan vielleicht
können sie da ja auch noch mal ein gutes
wort einlegen
dann wenn wir uns die digitale seite
dieses haushaltes und des hauses
anschauen dann müssen wir dann müssen
wir uns zwei themen klar machen wir
haben die großen geostrategischen
veränderungen zum beispiel den krieg in
der ukraine und die den wettbewerb den
system wettbewerb mit china und wir
haben rasante technologische entwicklung
und vor diesem hintergrund müssen wir in
deutschland in europa einen digitalen
aufbruch und digitale souveränität
organisieren und wir haben mit diesem
haushalt ganz entscheidende
weichenstellungen im vergleich zur
letzten legislaturperiode gesetzt meine
damen und herren
und ich will da auch minister wissen und
seinem haus danken denn das ist schon
auch kein leichtes erbe was sie da
angetreten haben das muss man einfach
sagen das gehört zur wahrheit hier mit
dazu und
vor dem hintergrund des kriegs in der
ukraine und alle dem was wir hier jede
woche auf den weg bringen müssen was wir
diskutieren müssen stichwort
sondervermögen und so weiter haben wir
gemeinsam auch im bundestag im digital
ausschuss jede menge themen auf den weg
gebracht das thema gigabit strategie
digitalstrategie mindestversorgung wir
haben die ganzen europäischen dossiers
den digital services digital markets act
und noch viel mehr also sich hier als
opposition hinzustellen und zu sagen ja
alles zu wenig und könnte noch viel mehr
ja das ist irgendwie am ende auch ein
bisschen unterkomplex angesichts der
situation in dem wir gerade sind meine
damen und herren
und es ist natürlich auch wichtig dass
wir die infrastruktur in deutschland
stärken und jetzt hat quasi hat der
geistige vater der so genannten
mobilfunkinfrastruktur gesellschaft
direkt vor mir geredet herr kollege
lange und das sieht man einfach auch
dass veränderung gut tut die
mobilfunkinfrastruktur gesellschaft ist
in der letzten legislaturperiode im
verkehrsministerium geboren worden und
an die scheuer eine ganz gute idee
eigentlich wollte mehr handymasten ins
land bringen das sind geschäftsführer
eingestellt worden da sind gute verträge
gemacht worden und jetzt raten sie mal
wie viele handymasten hat diese
mobilfunkinfrastruktur aus dem hause
scheuer gebaut jemanden idee ja nein sie
hat mehr als 0 gebaut sie hat einen
gebaut und da drüben sitzt da drüben
sitzt mein kollege da drüben sitzt mein
kollege johannes schätzel aus passau der
freut sich der freut sich weil in passau
ist der einzige handymast gebaut worden
hat mir eben noch mal erklärt da gibt es
fünf empfangen ich bin mir sicher das
ist eine der erfolge aus den ersten
tagen im deutschen bundestag es könnte
aber auch zufällig daran liegen dass es
auch der wahlkreis von andy scheuer ist
so viel schutz bewusst man erst mal
haben mit so einer bilanz und sowas hier
zu hinterlassen und ich führe das
hieraus nicht weil das irgendwie
ironisch oder lustig ist sondern weil es
eben wirklich nochmal zeigt was die
ausgangslage ist mit der wir hier
gemeinsam mit dem haus arbeiten müssen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
es ist aber im digitalbereich natürlich
nicht nur das digital ministerium
zuständig wir reden momentan ganz viel
über cyber sicherheit vor dem
hintergrund des kriegs gegen die ukraine
und deswegen begrüße ich das
ausdrücklich dass in den
haushaltsverhandlungen in der
bereinigungssitzung noch zusätzliches
geld für das
bundesinnenministerium für die
digitalisierung dort bereitgestellt
werden konnte dass wir themen wie das
digital institut das zentrum für
digitale souveränität dass wir das alles
jetzt wie wir es im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart haben auf den weg bringen
können das ein großer erfolg und dafür
einen herzlichen dank unseren
haushälterinnen haushältern der
koalition
wichtig ist aber jetzt auch dass wir so
wie wir es diese woche dann auch
beschließen werden neben dem
sondervermögen dann auch uns jetzt daran
machen die cybersicherheit die resilienz
wie man neudeutsch sagt unseres landes
im digitalen bereich zu stärken das wird
eine große aufgabe für die
haushaltsverhandlungen im jahr 20 23
aber ich kann für die
spd-bundestagsfraktion ich glaube aber
auch für die ganze koalition zu sagen
dass wir alles dafür tun werden dass wir
in zukunft sicher in deutschland im netz
unterwegs sein könnten herzlichen danke
danke könne hier
nicht rednerin ist die kollegin zwar
ziemlich lesen wird es 90 gewesen
sehr geehrter präsident sehr geehrte
kolleginnen in diesem jahr sieht der
haushalt so viel geld für den radverkehr
vor wie nie zuvor mehr als 750 millionen
stehen dafür zur verfügung und das ist
auch bitter nötig denn landauf landab
fehlte von guten sicheren und
komfortablen wegen für den radverkehr
dabei zeigen umfragen dass für immer
mehr menschen der klimaschutz eine
zentrale rolle spielt und immer mehr
menschen sind bereit ihre eigene
mobilität zu verändern mehr als 40
prozent würden gerne mehr fahrradfahren
damit ist das fahrrad das verkehrsmittel
mit dem höchsten verlagerung scott
enzian
40 millionen autofahrten jeden tag sind
kürzer als zwei kilometer davon könnte
ein riesiger teil mit dem rad
zurückgelegt werden wenn die
infrastruktur da wäre deshalb
investieren wir in diesem jahr in rad
schnell wege ins radnetz deutschland und
in radwege an bundesfernstraßen
gelegen ein neues programm auch für
fahrrad parkhäuser an bahnhöfen um die
kombination aus rad und öpnv zu stärken
und für das sonderprogramm stadt und
land stehen mehr als 500 millionen euro
zur verfügung damit die kommunen die
radwege vor ort ausbauen sicher und
attraktiv machen können denn die wege
vor ort sind es die die menschen zum
umsteigen einladen deshalb ist es so
wichtig und so richtig dass wir auch den
fußverkehr endlich in den blick nehmen
mit einem eigenen haushaltstitel über
eine million euro steigen geeinten
herstellung einer nationalen strategie
mit rad und fußverkehr rückt die
mobilität von menschen in den
mittelpunkt zusammen mit einem gut
ausgebauten pnv machen wir so nämlich
fast alle menschen aktiv mobil und das
nützt nicht nur dem klima sondern führt
auch zur lebenswerten städten und
gemeinden und es stärkt teilhabe und
barrierefreiheit
jetzt ist es an uns diesen trend
fortzusetzen und auch in den nächsten
jahren für eine auskömmliche
finanzierung zu sorgen 20 22 ist
jedenfalls ein sehr guter anfang vielen
dank für dein kollegin
franziska
hofmann ist die nächste rednerin sie
sitzt im ausschuss für digitales ist
mitglied der unionsfraktion und
kollegen sehr geehrter herr minister
lieber herr wissen anscheinend haben sie
zu viel damit zu tun sich mit ihrem
kollegen haben habe ich über die zukunft
der elektromobilität zu bringen statt
sich mit der digitalisierung
deutschlands zu befassen sie haben
offensichtlich vergessen dass das beben
die frauen nicht nur für verkehrspolitik
zuständig ist sondern auch für die
digital politik in deutschland
oder es ist es am ende vielleicht gar
nicht wie unser wimmelbild neulich aus
einer der ersten reden gezeigt hat hier
zeigt sich nämlich schon der erste große
fehler es hätte ein digital ministerium
geben müssen nicht nur den namen des
ministeriums zu ändern das reicht bei
weitem nicht aus dass es in ketten
schwindel herr minister
der jetzt zu beschließende haushalt ist
genau dafür wieder ein beispiel man ist
sich bei ihnen im haus anscheinend noch
nicht klar dass sie nicht nur für die
physische sondern auch die digitale
infrastruktur des landes zuständig sind
schauen wir doch einmal in den
koalitionsvertrag was sie ursprünglich
geplant hatten man staune ist denn dort
schreiben sie ich zitiere deutschland
braucht einen umfassenden digitalen
aufbruch wir wollen das potenzial der
digitalisierung für die
entfaltungsmöglichkeiten der menschen
für wohlstand freiheit soziale teilhabe
und nachhaltigkeit nutzen kompetenzen in
der bundesregierung werden neu geordnet
und gebündelt ein zentrales zusätzliches
digital budget eingeführt und gesetze
einem digitalisierung check unterzogen
für diese aussagen koalitionsvertrag hat
die regierung viele vorschusslorbeeren
bekommen der bitkom verband lobte auch
hier beispielsweise dass die
digitalisierung erstmals auf augenhöhe
mit am kabinettstisch setzte eine
bündelung der kompetenzen ist notwendig
und absolut zielführend das gegenteil
ist in ihrer verantwortung jedoch leider
der fall und das zeigt sich noch
deutlicher im haushalt weit und breit
kein detail sichtbar jedes ressort macht
seine digital vorhaben eigenständig
weiter und weitet sie aus das kanzleramt
veranschlagt neue wohlgemerkt 78
millionen euro für digital kompetenz der
ministerien warum auch immer und ein
mitglied der koalitions fraktionen
bezeichnete zuletzt das innenministerium
als eigentliches digital ministerium
eine kompetenzbündelung muss sich vor
allen dingen in den ressourcen abbilden
denn wer die musik bezahlt bestellt auch
was gespielt wird
mit dieser art der digital politik wie
sie sie betreiben ist weder eine
kompetenzbündelung noch eine
einheitliche steuerung und ein
controlling möglich die einführung eines
digital budgets wäre ein entscheidender
schritt gewesen um die digitalisierung
im land voranzubringen sie haben diese
chance klar verpasst herr minister
bündeln sie denn digitale kompetenz wenn
nicht im ministerium für digitales und
verkehr das kann nicht sein dass
deutschland in fragen der
digitalisierung noch länger an hinterher
hängt die chancen die mit der
digitalisierung verbunden sind müssen
ausgeschafft werden anstatt doch
stattdessen hat die ampel regierung die
zuständigkeiten und die mittel für
digitalisierung bis hin zur
unübersichtlichkeit verteilt der jetzt
vorgelegte haushalt unterstützt dieses
chaos noch und jeder kocht sein eigenes
süppchen ihre parlamentarische
staatssekretärin club hat schien das im
april noch erkannt zu haben als sie in
großen tönen davon sprach dass die
bundesregierung mit dem digital logic
ganz konkret verbesserungen für die
menschen in diesem land schaffen wolle
nicht erst 2030 sondern schon jetzt in
dieser legislaturperiode
diesen gedanken hätte die kollegin
vielleicht einmal mit dem rest der
regierung teilen sollen dann entgegen
ihrer eigenen ankündigungen im
koalitionsvertrag
wird es im haushalt 22 keine digitale zu
geben was soll man nicht mit
haushaltsmitteln hinterlegt ist kann
auch nicht umgesetzt werden und es
findet schlichtweg nicht statt
stattdessen kündigen sie jetzt an die
digitalstrategie noch in diesem quartal
also bis ende juni vorzulegen man darf
gespannt sein und sie erklären ein
digital budget können erst danach folgen
parallel aber das wissen vor allem
haushaltspolitiker steht aber der
haushalt 20 23 intern schon vor dem
abschluss wie und wann also genau das
digital budget und die kompetenz belogen
dann umgesetzt werden herr minister wie
fanden sie das was sie im
koalitionsvertrag versprochen haben
fassen wir ihre bemühungen im bereich
der digitalisierung am ende ganz einfach
zusammen so traurig es ist es kreiste
der berg und gebar eine maus vielen
herzlichen dank
kollegin
als nächster redner gilt das wort der
kollege matthias stein spd fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
bürgerinnen und bürger die
bundesregierung hat schon einen sehr
guten
regierungsentwurf zum haushalt im
bereich verkehr vorgelegt herzlichen
dank für diese vorarbeit aber wir haben
im parlamentarischen verfahren hier noch
mal eine deutliche schippe draufgelegt
und diesen haushalt deutlich besser
gemacht und da sind wir nicht nur bei
schönheitsreparaturen gelandet sondern
wir haben harte kräftige
sanierungsarbeiten geleistet und da gilt
mein dank an die haushälterin und
haushältern der ampel koalition der
grünen der fdp und natürlich auch an
meinen kollegen mit ihm hat werden
herzlichen dank
wir wollen damit gestalten und nicht nur
verwalten und das ist uns an vielen
stellen im verkehrsbereich gelungen wir
wollen eine moderne nachhaltige
mobilität für die bürgerinnen und bürger
dieses landes und es ist wichtig dass
wir auch etwas für den umwelt für den
klimaschutz tun und dafür tun wir eins
wir müssen mehr verkehr auf die schiene
und auch die wasserstraße verlagert um
dies möglich zu machen ist dies ideal
wenn man das miteinander verbindet und
deshalb kommt den kombinierten verkehren
hier eine schlüsselrolle zu und da haben
wir als ampelkoalition haben wir akzente
gesetzt in unseren haushaltsanträge wir
stellen insgesamt 77,6 millionen euro
zur verfügung damit umschlags anlagen
container terminals erstellt werden und
das so die kombination aus china aus
wasserstraßen aus häfen besonders gut
funktioniert und das sind ganze 15
millionen euro mehr als der
bundesfinanzminister und der
bundesverkehrsminister
zur verfügung gestellt und ihr nehmen
dieses geld von der straße so dass wir
dann auch doppelt verlagern können
und wird wohl auch 1 ich kenne noch als
wasserbauer wir haben oft die
unterhaltungs titel im bereich der
infrastruktur wasserstraßen gespart und
damit haben wir ein ende bereitet die
haben fünf millionen euro zusätzlich
bereitgestellt damit die wasserstraßen
auch vernünftig saniert werden kann und
das nicht nur für 22 sondern wir werden
das auch in den folgejahren fortsetzen
für eine verlässliche infrastruktur
außerdem brauchen wir für unsere
wasserstraßen moderne stiffel wir haben
mit den koalitionspartner der union aber
auch mit vielen anderen der
zusammenarbeit ein förderprogramm für
die binnenschifffahrt aufgelegt und wir
haben jetzt dafür gesorgt dass wir im
letzten haushalt schon von 6 millionen
auf 30 millionen gegangen sind und wir
haben den kraftakt erreicht dass wir
jetzt auch noch zehn millionen euro
zusätzlich zur verfügung gestellt haben
so dass auch die binnenschifffahrt als
wichtige branche klimaneutral werden
kann und das ist eine gute nachricht
die gut für die umwelt gut für den
klimaschutz und meistens auch gesund für
die gut für die gesundheit ist der
radverkehr
damit die förderprogramme modellvorhaben
die wir in den letzten jahren aufgelegt
hat weitergehen können werden wir 110
millionen euro zusätzliche
verpflichtungsermächtigungen
bereitstellt denn wir wissen jährlich
kite des haushalts ist oft ein problem
und das bringt planungssicherheit für
die beteiligten in den kommunen und
bundesländern
und dann noch zum thema
fußverkehr von vielen sehr unterschätzt
aber doch von allen genutzt und auch von
herrn rösler der sich jetzt net
unterhält denn es ist die einfachste
älteste und flexibelste form der
mobilität und die ampel koalition wollen
wir diesen verkehrsträger stärken und
mehr aufmerksamkeit zukommen lassen als
er bisher verdient habe und deshalb ist
es richtig dass wir einen eigenen
haushaltstitel dafür geschaffen haben
wir stellen eine million euro bereit für
eine nationale fußverkehr strategie und
das ist richtig so insofern werden wir
mit den haushalt mit diesem haushalt und
auch den nächsten haushalten mehr tun
für eine nachhaltige mobilität für eine
bessere infrastrukturen für einen guten
sozialen zusammenhalt vielen dank
vielen dank herr keller steinig jahren
gesehen haben
ich hoffe nicht mehr radverkehr
ansonsten wünsche ihm alles gute gute
besserung gute besserung wir werden
nochmal genesungswünsche von bundestags
vizepräsident wolfgang kubicki und damit
kommen wir zur letzten rednerin zu
diesem einzelplan das ist caroline
wagner für die spd-fraktion
digitale transformation
das ist nicht etwa der untertitel eines
neuesten hollywood blockbusters nein es
ist das schlagwort für den tief
greifenden digitalen umbau aller
lebensbereiche und diesen umbau dann
packen wir als fortschritt regierung
endlich an und warum weil es nicht sein
kann dass sich deutschland in sachen
digitale wettbewerbsfähigkeit im
vergleich mit anderen ländern in europa
seit jahren unter den schlusslichtern
einreiht dieses abgelenkt sein können
wir uns und wollen wir uns vor allem
nicht länger leisten und deshalb macht
es die ampel hier genauso wie in allen
anderen bereichen wir übernehmen
verantwortung wir gestalten
ganz zentral hierbei ist doch die
digitalisierung im bildungsbereich
gerade an unseren schulen wurde
digitalisierung doch jahrelang nur als
schulprojekt verfolgt und genau das ist
uns in der korona handel mir auch vor
die füße gefallen mit dem digital packt
schule wurde konkret gehandelt um die
digitale bildungs infrastruktur auf
vordermann zu bringen damit schulen auch
wirklich für eine arbeitswelt und eine
lebenswelt 4.0 vorbereiten wir werden
den digital packt schule bis ins jahr 20
30 fortführen den mittelabfluss
beschleunigen und nehmen hier für
richtig viel geld in die hand um endlich
in der schulischen bildung auf die
überholspur zu wechseln
die digitale transformation vollzieht
sich aber eben auch in allen anderen
bereichen zum beispiel in der
arbeitswelt und hierfür leistet diese
regierung auch ihren beitrag indem wir
zum beispiel mittel zur förderung
innovativer maßnahmen zur gestaltung der
arbeitswelt in der transformation auf
39,7 millionen euro erhöhen und was
steckt hinter dieser titel gruppe im
haushalt da steckt etwa die nationale
bildungsziele online
weiterbildungsplattform now dahinter
diese plattform findet
weiterbildungsangebote und verknüpft
fördermöglichkeiten mit maßnahmen wie
dieser erhöhen via
weiterbildungsbeteiligung der
beförderung von unserer seite den
digitalen strukturwandel und wir
unterstützen die bürgerinnen und bürger
bei der erschließung neuer beruflicher
qualifikation und entwicklungswege
digitale transformation sie findet
überall statt auch in unseren städten
und kommunen die wir fit machen müssen
für die zukunft lassen sie mir hier
schon einen blick auf die nächste
haushaltsdebatte werfen mit dem
förderprogramm für smarte die jung smart
smart regionen für das der bund bisher
820 millionen euro bereit gestellt hat
haben wir erste modellprojekte initiiert
die jetzt vor ort quasi grundlagenarbeit
leisten für clever vernetzte nachhaltig
und partizipative städte und gemeinden
und dieses zarte pflänzchen gilt es in
den nächsten jahren ausreichend zu
gießen das heißt wir müssen in den
kommenden jahren hier weitere mittel
bereitstellen um in der breite die
kommunen in diesem land smart zu machen
auch das hat die ampel im blick und
werden wir anpacken
unser anspruch als fortschritt koalition
ist es die digitale transformation in
diesem land zu gestalten und nicht sie
aus der lauerstellung heraus zu
beobachten wir stärken das gemeinwohl
und die teilhabe aller und genau dazu
soll digitale transformation auch dienen
und genau dafür steht unsere
bundesregierung vielen herzlichen dank
vieler frau kollegin war damit schließe
ich die aussprache gekommen zur
abstimmung der einzelplan 12
bundesministerin für digitales und
verkehr in der ausschuss fassung hierzu
liegt ein änderungsantrag der fraktionen
der cdu/csu auf drucksache 2038 vor wer
stimmt für diesen änderungsantrag
union linke wer stimmt dagegen der rest
des hauses damit dieser änderungsantrag
abgelehnt dann kommen wir zur abstimmung
über den einzelplan 12 in der ausschuss
fasste dieser änderungsantrag war von
der unionsfraktion da wollte die
fraktion noch mal investitionen für den
bedarfsplan schiene erhöhen wurde aber
hier von den abgeordneten abgelehnt